the way you approach your leadership and
the way you talk about your students in
your school which is you're totally open
to complaints but unlike many leaders
you push the accountability and
responsibility on those who want the
change and then you Foster the
environment for that most really great
leaders are
fundamentally unafraid and I don't like
the definition of courage that says
courage isn't the absence of fear yes it
is I'm Not Afraid hm I I am aware of
danger but there's really nothing you
can do to make me afraid it's all going
to be okay as long as you have people
around you that's it that's it what you
just said it's all going to be okay
whether it's the snowstorm or whether
it's a political upheaval in the country
it's this undying that it's all going to
be okay that's what it is that sums you
up